hey GQ we're the Jonas Brothers and
we're taking the brothers quiz
all right guys what am I bringing to the
family potluck oh pumpkin pie Wings
props popcorn
tequila all those things are are pretty
good but I would go with the first
answer pumpkin pie once do we get points
universally even if it's like July yeah
pumpkin pies describe my perfect day off
you start your day by waking up and
finding the most bougie most third wave
coffee shop that you can find in
whatever City you're in that's number
one okay I'm gonna keep my mouth shut
until afterwards because this is a I
need the full answer here then you have
and it's gonna be a long day it's gonna
be in the very long way yeah you know
like have an exceptional brunch so far
so good and you can walk to an art
gallery pop into a store that sells like
one item only because they do it really
well but they like make like pencil
erasers but they're exceptional and then
you're gonna go to a second look brunch
which is also lunch because then your
friends meet you right have I had a
drink yet no that's where you have to do
that's where it happens what is it what
am I drinking you're going to depends on
you're gonna have an eyeball Spirits
yeah they beat you to it so it's a drink
that's a point for Nick you get two
points for the morning so far and then
hopefully there's a great sporting event
on that night which is key for a perfect
day and back at the the hotel for a
nightcap before crashing out at 10 45
missing one important uh thing espresso
Martini I didn't think about that I'll
take that too that's another point
something we missed probably gonna be
doing some gaming as well gaming oh
video gaming video gaming nice waking
game that's pretty sounds like a great
day uh I want that day growing up which
brother got under my skin the most
both of us probably both of us an equal
amount
yeah
growing up yeah
no points no points minus
if I had to wear the same outfit for the
rest of my life what would it be golf
clothes no you wear a really good pair
of jeans with an amazing hoodie wrong
all right so we lose that what would it
be I have a rule you never want to be
under dressed right you can't be
underdressed tuxedo a black suit black
suit okay just a black suit white or
black shirt Works go to the beach black
suit yeah no one's gonna be like oh that
guy looks incredibly underdressed might
say I'm overdressed never under but I
came prepared I like to see you working
out in a full suit too that'd be nice
who would make me Star Struck Daniel
Craig Daniel Craig correct boom I said
it before the question was asked we knew
it was trending yeah Daniel Craig's
Direction what is my favorite song we've
made together and bonus my least
favorite your favorite song is
vacationize from the album
least favorite is uh Scandinavia
boom
got it why are you throwing he said we
could throw do I have any superstitions
you said that when we we are on a plane
we always do this we're doing we all do
this that is like the Superstition now
that like you'll do it even then like
your sleep if you feel like a takeoff
absolutely correct I also never say if
I'm sick never say I'm sick because then
it's not real no because then it is real
you can always it's all mental
till it's not if I wasn't a musician
what would I be probably be an art
dealer a potato farmer
wow well you're both almost right I'd be
a potato dealer
I don't like it how much was these
potatoes bro half point and a potato for
each other what is my ultimate comfort
food chicken parm I would go with a
bagel sandwich
that's that's a point for both of them
you get the chicken parm at night but if
it's comfort food in the morning you get
a tailor him egg and cheese on a
everything bagel we're gonna do a
lightning round who's most likely to I
got Joe
Nick and Kevin and we will see who he's
most likely to who is the most likely to
keep a secret from the group
you are on fire not everybody needs to
know everything
does directly affect our lives at times
it says GQ band therapy right now yeah
who is most likely to plan an elaborate
date
unanimous I'm romantic most romantic
date I ever planned I rented a boat from
here right across the street actually
and we took it around the city it was
most likely to be late
um I think it's this right here but
they're gonna disagree with me yeah
that's what I thought you were gonna say
he's fashionably late though I'm late
for like the time that you know we're
supposed to be there but we always know
there's a little bit of wiggle room
right we were technically late today so
sorry GQ yeah so yes and it's this guy's
fault that was fault
I didn't like the pair of pants I was
you didn't like these pants I changed
for pants he changed his pants threw off
Kevin today and there you have it who's
most likely to borrow his brother's
stuff
um
technically today
he's borrowing a pair of my sunglasses
today but you borrowed my house for two
years
technically borrowed that's true you
kind of did I gave it back
[Laughter]
didn't I sunglasses House same thing air
tray tomato tomato
potato potato
who is most likely to cry while watching
a movie I mean obvi obviously sensitive
guy over here
this goes hand in hand with being
awesome okay who's most likely to get in
trouble growing up
this is the correct answer although Joe
would blame Kevin for a lot of things no
I was first born stuff you know like you
go through everything first it's
different they got away with everything
I just didn't really do like a lot of
dumb like you guys did so not that
I got away with it
chose not to do that stuff well you saw
what would happen two times in a row I
guess he learned from our mistakes
helpful so thank you you're welcome who
is the messiest
oh
so here's why I think myself I've have a
tendency to leave things oh that is true
actually I was shocked that you didn't
say that no it just pisses me off
actually and that's so notice I'm
working on it when Kevin stays at my
house he leaves half drank cans of
Lacroix everywhere and it pisses me off
who's most likely to host an incredible
dinner party
next to me oh wow thanks guys the Indian
cuisine at Casa
Jonas is fantastic who is most likely to
cheat at a board game oh my God what
they're gonna say
we're just telling the truth we're not
bullying him by the way yes
I just like to win
well I appreciate the only cost but also
we created a game while on tour oh
it's called Toronto
and it's pretty simple it's a dice game
it's to die and you basically are trying
to roll two fours four four uh and you
only get eight rolls to get two fours
somehow some people can magically get 10
rolls we get to the seventh roll and
give us a no no I'm I'm on this is my
this is my sixth roll it's money game
honestly so it's important that there's
honesty honesty is important apparently
I don't have any
who's most likely to take the longest to
get ready if you're talking about today
it was me the pants debacle who is most
likely to become president
there's gonna be any of us I think I
think actually you would be most likely
you're like the mayor you are like the
mayor mayor of Jersey the whole state
that'd be governor I know I think Nick
carries himself very well well spoken
who's the most likely to get a tattoo on
a whim
I was thinking about getting one today I
got about 20 minutes break later we can
probably whip something up I gotta add
another initial in my hand I've got a
couple like I got a couple things that I
need to add
to complete the project you and I have
yes the arrows that pull into each other
when we stand back to back oh yeah I do
have a Brother's tattoo I'm gonna get
one that's like me like this in the
middle of the two arrows who's most
likely to spend a month backpacking
without telling anyone all of us have
kids now so we can't just uh disappear
and go backpacking but if
we didn't tell anyone else but I'm
saying yeah I love to travel and I do
have a lot of great camping backpacks
who's most likely to eat something off
the ground how long like are we talking
like it's been sitting there you walk up
to it or like just because he answered
like that I'm gonna go with Kevin it
wouldn't even be a question I'd say no
the five second rule sure but I said
we're talking about like you know so I'm
asking specifics
I'll go with you all right let's see who
is the winner
clearly
I think we all did very well and we had
we had good answers I think so the
lightning round seems to be taking
longer than the original round yeah well
this will be a lot to unpack in therapy
but we appreciate you all watching thank
you GQ see you next time yeah bye GQ